aumenta la tensión entre china y taiwán
por cuarto día consecutivo la
superpotencia asiática dirigió decenas
de aeronaves a sobrevolar y traspasar la
zona de defensa aérea de su isla vecina
en respuesta a taipei está escalando su
retórica militar
definitivamente taiwán necesita estar en
alerta chinas está cada vez más
desmedida el mundo también ha visto cómo
china reiteradamente ha violado la paz
regional presionando a taiwán así que
los países democráticos han alertado que
nuestros ciudadanos deben estar
preparados
las repetidas maniobras aéreas sobre
taiwán han desencadenado la reacción de
la casa blanca que defiende la soberanía
de taipei continuamos preocupados por la
actividad militar provocadora de la
república popular china acerca de taiwán
la cual es desestabilizadora porque
puede conllevar errores de cálculo y
socava la paz y la estabilidad regional
china reivindica taiwán como su
territorio que debe ser recuperado por
la fuerza si es necesario una amenaza
que pesa sobre la isla desde hace
décadas y con la que taipei ha aprendido
a vivir e incluso aprovechar
y ahora nosotros esta presión es incluso
un estímulo que nos exige estar
preparados en un artículo de la revista
foreign affairs la presidenta taiwanesa
de jim webb alertó que una invasión
china de la isla tendría consecuencias
catastróficas para la paz en asia y
declaró que está dispuesta a cualquier
cosa para defenderse